hey everyone
welcome to simply learns youtube channel
in this session
we will discuss the top coding books but
before we begin
make sure that you have subscribed to
our youtube channel and
don't forget to hit that bell icon to
never miss an update
from simply learn if you're a coder then
you should be a good reader
it helps you enhance your coding skills
based on the current
trends before getting started with code
a coder
should understand the requirements the
right books will help you enrich your
programming
and debugging skills so we bring you a
list of books
each with a different perspective that
will help you gain
an overall expertise in the field of
coding
so without further ado let's get started
with our first coding book in this
session
so the first book in our docket is
automate the boring stuff
with python this book was written by a
great author
mrs wagat and published in the year
2015.
swagat is a software developer and also
a passionate tech author
he loves to develop codes in python so
he used python language in this book in
this book you will learn how to use
python
for writing programs which is mainly for
beginner level programmers
it will help you in learning and
creating programs using python
this helps you to get the knowledge on
automating the keyboard and mouse
and web scraping this book also helps in
split merging encryption of pdfs
now why should you go for it the author
of this book mentioned a step-by-step
explanation
for each and every program that makes
learning curve linear
and you can get started with your coding
like icing on the top of cake
this book is completely for beginners so
no
hardcore coding knowledge is required
and also
to advance to the next level this book
helps you with some practice programs
there are practice questions at the end
of each chapter to get more ideas about
python and
improve the programming skills these are
the few reasons
to make you choose this book for
learning to code
next in the docket is clean code
a handbook of agile and craftsmanship
this book was written by a great author
robert martin
this book will help you plot that next
breakthrough to become a professional
programmer
this book was published in the year 2008
and it is suitable for software
developers
team lead project managers to produce
better code
this book is divided into three parts
the first part describes the principles
patterns and writing clean code the
second part
describes several case studies with
exercises
the third part will walk you through a
single chapter containing a list of
heuristics
this book gives an idea for coders to
know all the minute and delicate
differences between a good and a bad
code
this book also improves the state of
craftsmanship and
fixing the bugs in the code why should
one
go for it the author robert martin
used proper code and neat explanations
for each and every code
to make it easy for everyone to
understand how
quotes are written robert also explained
how to transform
and create names classes functions and
error handling
challenges are provided at the end of
every chapter to make it easy for
every reader to implement codes in real
time
if you're interested in producing better
code this book is the best choice for
you
moving up to the next book we have
programming pearls
programming pearls was written by joe
bentley
the programming pulse offers unique
solutions to nagging problems
this book was published in the year 1986
this book offers solid techniques and
solutions to computer programs
in this book bentley mainly focused on
three essays testing bugging and
timing set representation string
problems
this book is covered with practical
problems and effective solutions
the main highlight of this book is
delightful reading
and the writing style is simply
outstanding
now why should you go for it in this
book
bentley mainly focused on hardcore
coding problems to deliver
workable solutions for the coders and
programmers
it challenges the outstanding concepts
of cpu memory
and algorithms bentley focuses on
principles and key techniques for easy
understanding for the readers
the next book in the session is the
clean coder
a coder of conduct for professional
programmers
much more than the rules and guidelines
which was written by the author robert
martin
is published in the year 2011.
this book covers tools and techniques
for true software craftsmanship
the key factor of this book is practical
advice on refactoring and
testing now why should one
go for it through this book martin shows
how to approach
software development with honor
self-respect and pride
and also this book demonstrates avoiding
common pitfalls in software development
now moving forward the next book of the
session is
code complete a practical handbook of
software construction
this book was written by steve mcconnell
and published in the year
1993 he is the author of
multiple software engineering books and
an expert in software development and
project management it is fully loaded
with integration architecture
testing and leading edge coding concepts
of
software development now why should one
go for this book this book is a massive
piece of literature
packed with techniques and suggestions
to improve everyday programming
steve covered this book with big
projects to make it easy for everyone to
improve coding skills
now the next book in the list is the rf
computer programming which is written by
the author
donald nutt this book was published in
the year
1968 with four volumes it is a computer
monograph that covers many kinds of
programming algorithms and their
analysis
this book mainly covers and represents
the inside concepts of a computer
the key concepts of this book are
programming algorithms
fundamental algorithms sorting and
searching
now why should one go for this book this
book mainly covers the chief technical
aspects of the algorithms and their
analysis
every chapter of this book is explained
with clean code and flowcharts that
is easy for every reader to understand
now the next book in the session is zero
bucks
and program faster which was written by
the author kate thompson
kate thompson is also known for being
the best writers of the children's
novels
she has spent two years of research and
find out the techniques of
bug avoidance this book was published in
august 2015.
this book gives an idea of improving
skills and avoiding
mistakes and coding in this book kate
mainly concentrated on bug avoidance
techniques and
implementing the secure code improving
skills and principles to avoid
bugs now why should one go for this book
this book helps to write code in a
secure way that improves the security of
the code and
it helps to improve the coding time by
reducing the effort with
fewer bucks now moving forward the next
book is
introduction to algorithms this book was
written by the author
thompson common and published in the
year 1989.
this book provides a comprehensive
introduction to modern study of computer
algorithms
it represents many algorithms and covers
them in
considerable depth and makes their
design and analysis
accessible to all levels of readers some
of the key
features of this book are pseudo code
arithmetic algorithms
and arithmetic circuits now why should
one
go for this book each chapter of this
book presents an algorithm
a design technique and an application
area or a related topic
algorithms are described in english and
in a pseudocode designed to be readable
by anyone
who has done a little programming this
book also covers
the depth of greedy algorithms and
mathematical rigor
the next book in the list is rapid
development
taming wild software schedules this book
is written by
steve mcconnell this book was published
in the year 1996
and this book helps in improving the
development speed of rapid development
and
risk management and also prototyping
now why should one go for this book this
book is completely designed with an
overview of their projects and their
directions
which helps in avoiding the mystics for
rapid development including
creeping requirements short-changed
quality and
cellular bullet syndrome moving forward
the final book of this session is
hacking the art of
exploration second edition this book was
written by
john erickson and was published in the
year 2008.
this book is totally filled with real
code and hacking techniques
this book helps in providing the art of
creative problem solving tricks
and techniques on hacking and shell
scripts
now why should you go for this book this
book helps for the readers who are
interested in understanding exploits and
exploits development this book also is
helpful
for the readers who are finding
solutions for complex problems
and with that we have come to an end of
this session i hope this session
gave you a list of the best books that
you're waiting for
if you have any queries regarding the
books discussed in this
session then please feel free to let us
know in the comment sections below our
team of experts will be happy to resolve
all your queries
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here